turkey has been home to these Syrian
families for years after they fled the
Civil War in their country
many of them lost their loved ones in
the earthquake in Northwest Syria
they are waiting to cross into Syria to
attend their funerals and meet those who
survived
bodies of the Syrian refugees who lost
their lives on the Turkish side are also
being sent back home for burials
here for most Aid is the only lifeline
they're about to get that Lifeline via
Qatar Aid and Qatar rat Crescent
this is the second eight Convoy Senpai
Qatar to Northwest Syria in the last two
days
these rebel-held areas were heavily
bombed by the regime throughout the 12
year long Civic War
last week's earthquake has made things
worse killing thousands and injuring
many more
ridersale the head of the Syrian Civil
Defense Forces also known as white
helmets says the global response to the
disaster has been too little
I've had the most difficult seven days
of my life we've been forgotten for
years and the world didn't hear us if
the world had heard our voice we
wouldn't have lost these Souls
Province where the earthquake hit the
hardest Aid is desperately needed
we've been displaced several times in
the last nine years we don't know what
is ahead of us this earthquake displaced
us again we lost our homes families we
need shelter
the Qatari Aid Convoy has brought tents
diapers heaters gas cylinders blankets
food and medical kids
we've been ordered by the Emir of Qatar
to keep the aid supply line open for the
syrians we now see that the Syrian
people need our support especially in
this cone crisis their pains now doubled
and the International Community needs to
step up its support in Northwest Syria
hospitals already lack modern equipment
many survivors died on the way to
hospitals or soon after arrival
this region is home to more than 4
million people life here was already
tough and the earthquake has just added
to their misery
disasters overlap in Syria more than a
decade long Civil War has left very
little to syrians they have built
makeshift shelters it wasn't much but
still home and the earthquake has
destroyed that too many syrians feel
they have been neglected by the rest of
the world now the help is needed here
more than ever
Al Jazeera married Northwest Syria